My preliminary conclusion is there is no
middle ground
>> and historical critical uh method and
isad analysis
are two diametrically opposed ways of
looking at early Islam and reports and I
don't find much commonality between them
as of yet obviously in small areas but
overall two diametrically opposed epis
epistemologies.
That having been said, therefore,
one will have to navigate the religious
side of things if you are a believing
Sunni uh hadith believer in a different
epistemology. And when you are arguing
in the academic world, you'll have to
use a different epistemology.
So, in some areas there's good healthy
overlap. In some areas, we'll politely
agree to disagree. And in some areas
there
>> because of that extraordinary video I
want to pay tribute to one of the
foremost Islamic scholars in the United
States and indeed in the whole world Dr.
Yaser Kadi. I've been an admirer of Dr.
Kadi for many years and this video
validates my admiration.
What is he saying in this video? What
he's saying essentially is this that the
whole structure of Islam from beginning
to end is a castle built on sand. It's a
high-rise building with no first floor.
Because without the science of hadith,
which he has just dismissed in the video
you have just seen, Islam itself does
not and cannot exist. Now in the first
place in order to understand that we
have to understand what he means by the
science of hadith and you can see that
from this chart the hadiths of course
are reports about Muhammad's words and
deeds. Ones that are considered
authentic are considered normative for
Islamic law. And in order to consider a
a death authentic it has to be
classified as such. based on its isnad
that is the chain of transmitters who
have passed it from the people who first
told it at the time of Muhammad until
the 9th century when it was finally
written down. And so you see from the
chart that there are various grades of
hadith based on the reputations of the
people who passed it on based on uh
various other considerations
that will ultimately get it the grade of
sah or sound d which is weak or various
other grades and on that basis it is
considered authoritative or Not. Now
that's the science, but it's really not
a science. The problem is that the texts
that are being evaluated in this way are
all 200 years removed from the incidents
they claim to describe. And in many
cases, the chains of transmission, the
isnad chains upon which their claim to
authenticity is based are often even
later than the stories themselves. Yet
this is the basis for a great deal of
Islamic doctrine and practice. Even the
five daily prayers and the details of
what to pray during those five daily
prayers come from the hadith not the
Quran.
Now many Muslims nowadays say no no no
we just need the Quran alone because the
Quran itself says light from Allah and a
clear book has come to you. That's
chapter 5:15.
The clear book is supposed to be the
Quran itself. But the fact is only a
cursory reading is needed to establish
it isn't clear at all. Now I could give
a myriad of examples of this but just
just take one. The word zihar in chapter
58:2
that reads this way. Those of you who
put away your wives, they are not their
mothers. No one are their mothers except
those who gave them birth. They indeed
speak an evil word and a lie. And indeed
Allah is forgiving, merciful.
Now put away in that passage, those of
you who put away your wives is yuzahuna,
which is a word that is assumed in
various hadith to be referring to a
practice referred called zihar, which is
to say to your wife, you are like my
mother, which is essentially to
pronounce divorce.
But elsewhere in the Quran, the same
word zihar means aid or help or support.
For example, chapter 2:85
says, "Yet it is you who kill each other
and expel a party of your people from
their homes, supporting one another
against them by sin and aggression."
Supporting in that passage is tazaruna,
a form of the same word. Chapter 9
verse4 same thing except for those of
the idolattors with whom you have a
treaty and who have not been deficient
toward you nor have supported anyone
against you support in that passage is
you zahiru. So to use the Quran's own
common meaning of the word, we would
understand chapter 58:2 as saying,
"Those of you who supported your wives,
they're not your mothers."
Which of course would not make any
sense. So the hadith is needed in order
to make the Quran passage make any sense
at all. Other examples of this are the
story of the disobedient wives in the
Quran chapter 66 and of Zade and his
wife in chapter 33. The hadiths and both
of those cases flesh out the elliptical
and elusive text of the Quran and make
it understandable. And yet Yaserkati is
saying that all this is baseless and has
no historical value, which is exactly
what I've been pointing out for years.
The material from 200 years later is the
material on which so much of Islamic
doctrine and practices is based. And yet
that material has undergone a great deal
of legendary elaboration. So much so
that whatever really happened or
whatever was really said cannot be
discerned. But it's absolutely clear
that there has been le leg legendary
elaboration as there are so many stories
that have variations and different
forms, different versions and so on.
Now this means that non-Muslims who
insist that the hadith literature which
dates from 200 years after Muhammad is
supposed to have lived and has so many
signs of legendary elaboration.
Non-Muslims who claim that all that is
reliable are now in the very strange
position of being more of a believer
than one of the leading Islamic clerics
and scholars in the US Yaser Kadi. Now
Kadi of course is still a Muslim. He's
still a believer very much so. But he
acknowledges here that he understands
that his faith is blind. It has no
intellectual historical foundations. He
says this in a clarifying post on X
after this video came out. And in that
he says, just to be clear, I'm obviously
being descriptive in that lecture. What
I said is factually correct. The Western
Academy has a different paradigm than
the believing Sunni Muslim when it comes
to Hadith. I explicitly said when I
preach, I will quote Sah Al Bukhari as
an evidence of what the prophet said.
But I understand when I write papers or
present in the academy, that won't be
taken as definitive evidence. It appears
your clip is giving the impression I
endorse the HCM paradigm. That's the
historical critical method. But as I
explained, I live in both worlds and
must navigate that in my navigate that
in my life as I preach and as I present
papers. So he does not accept the
historical critical paradigm. In other
words, he's not saying that he doesn't
believe that Muhammad was real. He's
just admitting that to believe that
Muhammad is real has no historical ba
basis. There's no reason for it other
than he wants to be a Muslim. He wants
to believe in all this. And so even
though he knows it has no historical
foundation, he's going to keep on
believing it. He's going to keep on
pretending
that these passages about Muhammad,
these stories about Muhammad in the
Hadith, these quotations of Muhammad's
words and words, they all have a
historical foundation when they don't
really and he knows it. And so I really
want to thank Yaserkati in this case
from the bottom of my heart. He has now
validated the work that I've done
exposing the lack of historical
foundation of the Islamic texts and
teachings in my books did Muhammad exist
and Muhammad a critical biography. For
more details about this issue, you can
consult those books and see exactly why
Dr. Yaserkadi has now essentially
admitted that Muhammad, the prophet of
Islam, as described in the hadith, did
not exist. Thank you.